вітаємо Ласкаво просимо до програми
Європа У фокусі Мене звуть ліс шуу І я
рада знову бути з вами
кількість людей у Європі які помирають
від вживання наркотиків зростає У той
час як важкий наркотики заборонені у
більшості європейських країн Португалія
має інший підхід
країна докорінно змінила свою політику
до наркоманії ставляться як до хвороби
замість того щоб карати людям пропонують
допомогу незалежно від того вживають
вони марихуану Кокаїн чи героїн
понад 20 років тому Португалія
декриміналізувала всі види наркотиків у
прибережному місті Порту та інших
частинах країни і з правовими наслідками
стикаються переважно лише ті хто продає
наркотики
У той час як експерти схвалю цей крок і
вважають його прикладом для наслідування
для інших країн жителі Порту такі
Крістіану Сільва мають іншу точку зору
він незадоволений тим що наркомани
приймають наркотики в його районі і в
таких випадках Поліція часто виглядає
без силою
обгоріла фольга викинуті шприци та кров
усе це свідчить про вживання наркотиків
на вулицях і в парках Порту
Крістіану Сільва бачить це щодня він
живе у другому за величиною в місті
Португалії у районі середнього класу це
також місце де тусуються наркозалежні
це непова до решти суспільства вони
вживають відкрито на вулицю
якщо вам це не подобається Ви мусите
перейти на іншу сторону вулиці якщо ти
кажеш що це ненормально Вони стають
агресивними
Португалія декриміналізувала всі
наркотики у 2001 році незалежно від того
наскільки вони небезпечні той у кого
виявлять менш ніж десятиденний запас
наркотиків тепер просто отримує штраф до
в'язниці потрапляють лише дилери
ми їдемо з профспілковим активістом
поліції у гоморера
це район торгівлі наркотиками
нам погрожували через те що ми знімаємо
тому ми використовуємо мобільні телефони
щоб бути непомітними ми Обережно
наближаємося до них
там знаходиться їхнє місце зустрічі
краще уникати цього місця
вони можуть бути налаштовані ворожу
торгівля все що заборонена більша
частина торгівлі наркотиками
відбувається за зачиненими дверима хоча
вживання на вулиці заборонене воно рідко
має правові наслідки
оскільки нам більше не дозволено
заарештовувати тих хто вживає наркотики
проблема полягає в тому що ми стикаємося
з такими ситуаціями Все частіше у
поліції зв'язані руки
тим кого ловлять пропонують терапію
і такі наркологічні центри як цей
покликані забрати наркоманів з вулиці
але він єдиний на все Порту
приходить сюди щодня щоб під наглядом
викурити коктейль з героїну та кокаїну
ми люди хворі наркозалежні
і нам дуже потрібно допомога
[музика]
психологині Діана Кастро пишається
португальським законом щодо наркотиків
вона каже що це спосіб вивести хворих з
тіні
зрештою смертей від наркотиків стало
менше
коли вживання наркотиків вважається
злочином наркозалежні залишаються у ціні
поза увагою суспільства
вони не приймають пропозиції лікування
просто тому що на них дивляться як на
злочинців а не як на людей які
потребують допомоги
але послуг з лікування явно не вистачає
критики побоюються за громадську безпеку
насправді нам із працівником міської
адміністрації також погрожували нас
викрали коли ми намагалися таємно
знімати у цьому підземному переході
[музика]
для патриції рапазота такий стан речей
неприйнятний
вона мер району одного з найпроблемніших
районів Порту
коли треба обертатися і дивитися чи не
йде хтось за тобою Це неприйнятно
більше поліції більше патрулів на
вулицях
профспілка поліцейських також закликає
до жорсткіших заходів
ми виконуємо свою роботу робимо обходи
але якщо немає ніяких наслідків Я думаю
що нам потрібно заклад який би забирав
наркозалежних і примушував їх до
лікування
заклад з достатнім ресурсами і
професіоналами які піклувалися про них
після більш ніж 20 років ліберальної
політики щодо наркотиків Настав час
діяти вважає місцевий житель Крістіан
Сільва
Турбота про наркозалежних це дуже добре
але не за рахунок захисту населення
усе це призводить до відчуття що вони
можуть безкарно робити все що їм
заманеться
це дуже небезпечна спіраль
після великої поліцейської операції в
районі де живе Крістіано все трохи
заспокоїлося
але частина наркобізнесу просто
переїхала в іншу частину міста що явно
не вирішує проблеми Порту
минуло 18 місяців Від початку війни в
Україні
наразі немає жодних ознак того що бойові
дії закінчаться найближчим часом тому у
портовому місті Одеса як і в усій країні
українці навчилися жити в умовах
воєнного стану
діджей Анатолій пропонує своїм
шанувальникам таку необхідну перерву від
постійних думок про атаки на місто
здається що зараз як ніколи люди
налаштовані використовувати кожну
можливість радіти життю
у 2015 році світ зібрався разом щоб
підписати історичну угоду стосовно
зупинення кліматичних змін паризьку
угоду вісім років потому не дивно що
столиця Франції стоїть на чолі зусиль у
боротьбі з підвищенням глобальної
температури
Садівник Валентин галлер робить свій
внесок а він обрав дахи міських будівель
своїм основним полем битви у боротьбі із
кліматичними змінами
Валентин галє задоволений цьогорічним
урожаєм квасолі на найбільшій фермі на
даху у Парижі
квасоля
ціла купа
більшість людей які приїжджають сюди
дивуються
кажуть що не відчувають себе В самому
центрі Парижа
Париж трансформацію
багатьом набридли затори на дорогах і
забруднене повітря які роблять літо
майже нестерпним
французька столиця сподівається стати
кліматично нейтральною до 2050 року на
громадських будівлях висаджують дерева а
на дахах з'являються вертикальні ліси
дахи будинків перетворюються на
величезні овочеві плантації
неподалік Ейфелевої вежі знаходиться
найбільша у Європі Ферма на даху
Валентина галє
півтора гектара або еквівалент двох
футбольних полів
250 грамів Перевір чи добре закрита
кришка
фрукти та овочі звідси доставляють до
супермаркету що знаходиться Всього за 2
км від ферми
короткі відстані означають менші викиди
СО2 це безпрограшна ситуація для
довкілля
але як щодо якості продуктів
я налаштований неоднозначно тому що з
одного боку це добре адже все поруч і
викидить СО2 менше проте з іншого боку
тут дуже забруднене середовище
мушу визнати що мене не дуже цікавлять
продукти вирощені в місті Я віддаю
перевагу фруктам і овочам вирощеним у
сільській місцевості а в Парижі взагалі
дуже забруднене середовище
французький інститут
сільськогосподарських досліджень
сподівається розвіяти деякі сумніви на
цьому даху стоять ящики для фруктових
дерев а також шматок перелогової землі
щоб перевірити що тут росте природним
чином
Крістін обріта інститут шукають спосіб
просувати міське сільське господарство
вона вважає що продукти вирощені на
паризьких дахах не шкідливі
деякі німецькі колеги з Берлінського
університету близько 10 років тому
виявили що Як тільки ви піднімаєтесь
вище третього поверху ви вже не
знаходитеся в зоні забрудненій
транспорту
вона каже що ці ферми на дахах також
мають освітню функцію
є щонайменше 3-4 покоління міських
жителів які не мають жодних знань про
сільське господарство і не мають прямого
контакту з ним
тому більшість наших дітей і онуків не
знають як вирощувати помідори чи салат
Ось чому франкфуртє вберіг овочеву ферму
посеред типової бетонної пустелі у
передмісті Парижа
Як справи Йди до мене
вони трохи сором'язливі
забруднення повітря турбує його менше
ніж забруднена земля наприклад важкими
металами але він знайшов спосіб вирішити
цю проблему
коли грунт розпадається свинець буде
повільно опускатися особливо якщо є не
використовую рослин які б її отримували
якщо я не використовую шпинат польовий
салат моркву чи буряк який утримують
свинець він буде опускатися вниз
натомість він посадив їстівні квіти
чоловік каже що тести показали що в них
немає залишків свинцю і шеф-кухарі їх
дуже люблять
просто Візьміть крихітне зернятко воно
на смак нагадує цибулю порей Це просто
неймовірно
багато міських фермерів переконані що
існують рішення для боротьби з
проблемами які виникають в
індустріальному місці і держава фінансує
перспективні проєкти та фермерські
господарства по всій Франції їх уже
більше 300
не тільки в Парижі Але у всіх великих
містах Франції і навіть Європи
будується все більше і більше таких
дахів
і вже є багато архітекторів які думають
про те як використовувати їх для
рослинності та створювати зелені дахи
Валентин галєта його колеги планують
подвоїти площу своїх дахів у Парижі
Саме тут вони бачать економічне та
екологічне майбутнє
одна із найпопулярніших країн для
туристів з усієї Європи Греція щороку
мільйони людей відвідують материкову
частину тієї країни або острови такі як
наксос але останнім часом пляжі стають у
собі ж переповненими а доступ до лежаків
доволі дорогим
місцевим жителям таким як журналістка
іріні промпона це вже набридло вони
хочуть повернути свій рай на порозі
власних домівок
незвично видовище демонстранти на
залитих сонцем грецьких пляжах але в
наші дні Це не рідкість Ми хочемо
повернути наші пляжі скандують вони
місцева журналістка ірійні промпона
знайома з гнівом і обуренням на острові
наксус
остров'янам відмовляють у доступі до все
більшої кількості пляжів які тепер
зарезервовані для платних лежаків і
парасольок-підприємців
до Кер
Мом раптом з'явилося вільне місце зліва
зазвичай там повно сонцезахисних
парасольок
тож Схоже що вони побоюються перевірок
Але вони просто склали ті шезлонги збоку
вони не могли знати коли прийдуть
інспектори їх хтось попередив
сонце і блакитне море Грецький
кікландський острів наксус давно
перестав бути інсайдерським секретним
місцем щороку десятки тисяч туристів з
Греції та з-за кордону З'їжджаються на
його довжелезні піщані пляжі
доступ до них має бути вільним
[музика]
але бізнес заробляє на цьому гроші
здебільшого нелегально
місцеві підприємці поступово захоплюють
територію пляжу а потім здають шезлонги
та парасольки в оренду туристам
шезлонг з парасолькою коштує від 20 до
50 євро на день
навіть природні заповідники не в безпеці
як з'ясували журналістка промпона
добре
ось навіть екскаватор тут у заповіднику
це територія що особливого охороняється
з болотами і кипарисовим лісом
це особливо рідкісний ландшафт на
кіккладських островах
на одному лише наксусі тисячі людей
приєдналися до протестного руху врятуйте
пляжі сьогодні делегація має передати
петицію прокурору острова
її підписали понад 1500 мешканців
державу закликають зупинити це пляжне
свавілля
саме Міністерство фінансів Греції
відповідає за моніторинг того чи мають
орендарі контракти чи ні
вони порушують свої контракти але
проблема також і в самих контрактах які
вони мають
ці документи ймовірно у будь-якому
випадку незаконні
власник ресторану георгус має державний
дозвіл на свої пляжні шезлонги
те що на пляжі більше немає місця для
інших каже він також пов'язано зі
спекотною погодою
у нас повну туристів які шукають
шезлонги
і щоразу вони хочуть більше
вони буквально нас благають
температура зростає
без шезлонгітіні ви не протримайтесь на
пляжі п'яти хвилин
Це просто жалюгідні відмовки Кажуть все
більше греків вони хочуть повернути свої
пляжі і не тільки на наксусі по всій
країні проходять демонстрації проти
пляжних спекулянтів туристи ставляться
до протестів неоднозначно
Я за протести Це не добре Що все
приватизовано
пляж має бути громадською власністю
я фанатка шезлонгів
це зручніше і в тебе одночасно є і сонце
і тінь
вимагає від уряду втрутитися у це
беззаконня він боїться за репутацію
свого острова
саме візитор ще вийкомплей це велика
проблема не тільки для наксусу але для
всієї Греції
про відсутність належної координації між
державними службами
тим часом уряд посилив свій моніторинг і
навіть проводяться арешти
[музика]
побоюючись перевірок дехто збирає свої
незаконні пляжні меблі уночі але так
буде недовго бажає ірійні промкона
ння
штрафи розішлють або не розішлють
Ось так працює влада в цій країні через
деякий час парасольки повернуться як ні
в чому не бувало і боротьба почнеться
знову
рушники а не шезлонги гасло
протестувальників на наксусі і пляжі для
всіх безкоштовно А хто переможе у цій
битві за пляжі дізнаємося наступного
літа
[музика]
від пляжів Греції до швейцарських
гір вкрита вічною мерзлотою яка як
випливає з назви має бути шаром
постійного холоду
але підвищення температури танення
льодовиків спричиняють зміщення ґрунту
створюючи великі проблеми
тож на цьому завершується цей випуск
Європа У фокусі Дякуємо за перегляд і
підписуйтесь на нашу соцмережах Мене
звуть ліс Show до наступних зустрічей
[музика]